let's say that we have the function f of
x being defined by the second degree
polynomial
five x squared plus six x
plus five
the fundamental theorem of algebra tells
us that because this is a second degree
polynomial we are going to have exactly
two roots or another way of thinking
about it there's exactly two values for
x that will make f of x equal zero so i
encourage you to pause this video and
try to figure out what those two values
of x are
so when i if we're looking for the x
values that would make this expression
equal to 0 that's essentially trying to
solve this equation at 5x squared plus
6x plus 5 is equal to 0 and there's no
obvious way i can think of factoring
this right over here so i'll just resort
to the quadratic formula
so the quadratic formula tells us that x
where x is a solution to this equation
is going to be equal to
negative b
i'll try to color code it negative
b
this is right this is b right over here
negative b so negative 6
plus or minus
plus or minus the square root of b
squared
of b
minus 4 times a
times
a
times c
times a
all of that
all of that over all of that over
times a
all of that over 2 times a
so what does this simplify to this is
going to be equal to
so let me go back to this is going to be
equal to
negative 6. i'll try to keep it
color-coded still
negative 6 plus or minus
plus or minus the square root now what
is this going to be equal to this is 36
minus
a hundred so negative 64
all of that
over two times five all of that over ten
now this is interesting
we are trying to take the square root of
a negative number or another way of
thinking about it b squared minus 4ac
is less than zero
b squared
minus 4
a c which is oftentimes often times
called the discriminant this of this
quadratic this is less than zero so this
is less than zero this part of the
quadratic formula we're going to try to
take the square root of a negative
number this is going to be a negative
number so we're going to result in an
imaginary number and so what that gives
us are not two real roots but two
non-real complex roots so this is going
to be equal to
negative 6
plus or minus
8 i
8 i the square root of negative 64 is 8i
if we extend the the principal square
root function to imaginary numbers or
complex numbers all of that over 10 or
we could say
x is equal to
let's see if we if we find a greatest
common divisor if we try to reduce this
so we're going to have let's see they're
all divisible by 2. so it's negative
over 5. that's the same thing as
negative 6 over 10
plus or minus
over 5
4 over 5i or you could say that the two
roots which are non-real complex roots
so it's x is equal to negative
three-fifths
plus four-fifths i that's one of the
roots and then the other root is x is
equal to negative three-fifths
minus four-fifths i notice we satisfied
the fundamental theorem of algebra we
have two roots they're non-real but that
fundamental theorem algebra says hey
look we're just gonna have at least if
we're of nth degree polynomial we're
gonna have n complex roots they could be
real or they could be non-real and we
see that right over there we also see
that they are conjugates and the
quadratic formula kind of sets up a
situation where we are especially if
this ends up being less than zero and so
this when you take the square root you
get an imaginary number you see where
those conjugates appear now let's verify
graphically that this is indeed the case
this does not have any real roots so
let's get a calculator out
so let me go into graph mode
so y is equal to let me clear what i
must have been doing out here before so
y one is equal to five times x
squared
plus six x
plus five
and then let me set a reasonable range
here so i don't know actually i know
very little about this function right
over here so i'm going to set a minimum
range i know negative 10
x max i know positive 10
x scale is one let's see why max
let's see this thing actually does get
pretty big pretty fast so let's say
y max is i know the y scale i don't know
i'll say a hundred
a hundred the scale i'll make it ten
each of those notches are going to be
ten y minimum what's we want to see the
x axis to make sure it doesn't cross it
so let's go at negative i don't know
negative twenty and now let's graph this
i'm hoping that i've actually captured
it and i have so there you have it you
see that this thing does not intersect
the x-axis in fact we could we could
zoom in on it let's see it's a little
bit hard to
it's a little actually let me just
change the range a little bit
so let me just change the range so let's
make our x-min
let's make it five
let's make our x-max whoops not 50.
let's make that
five
and let's make negative five and
positive five
and then let's see let's make our y
max let's make our y max equal to 20
and then our y scale i know we can make
it 2.
okay i think this will get us much
closer in to there we see it does not
intersect the x-axis this does not have
any real roots but it has two non-real
complex roots